Film Courage: How does a filmmaker know how
much to spend in order to get their money
back?
Jeff Deverett, Film Producer, Entrepreneur,
Writer, Director: Great question.
This is where filmmakers get upset with distributors
because they usually get screwed by distributors,
that’s the truth because distribution is
a whole different business mindset.
They don’t have the sensitivity to filmmakers.
But distributors do serve a very good function
in the industry.
I mean they do know how much a movie is worth,
where to monetize it, where to sell it and
they have a pretty good idea how much they’re
going to get for it.
The best way to sort of find out what the
range will be, will be through a distributor.
Now there are sales agents who do these forecasts
for you.
They give you these ranges.
Most indie films when they are trying to get
financed they will get a sales agent to do
a range.
I’ve seen so many of them.
I don’t know if you’ve seen them but there
is the low, the middle and the high.
Sometimes there are five of them right?
They’re forecasts based on other like films
or comparisons.
You have to be super careful that you’re
comparing them to like films in the same sort
of time frame.
Sometimes they will compare to like films
that were released 10 years ago.
Well I mean 10 years ago was a completely
different market than it was today.
So you want the comps to be as accurate as
possible but they will do these comparisons
and they will say the middle range is sort
of what you can expect and it sort of it what
you can expect.
These are people who do this for a living.
They know where ultimately they are going
to sell it, where the market will bear, internationally
and from each player and they do a forecast
that do give you a pretty good idea - not
dead on but at least a range and that is the
best way to gauge it.
Film Courage: So similar to how a realtor
would get comps…well this is a fixer and
this is the square footage and so I think
your property will go for this or this one
you’ve just redone the kitchen and bathroom
and you’ve got a huge lot…similar?
Jeff: Correct, that’s the same thing.
I mean I think real estate is a little bit
more predicable and accurate because it’s
a confined area whereas film is the whole
world but it’s the same concept.
Film Courage: Does that mean if I pick up
the phone and just call a distributor they
will give me an idea of what my budget should
be?
Jeff: …Not necessarily.
I mean we should talk a little bit about distributors
and how to find a distributor and who is reputable
and who will give you the right answer assuming
they will even answer your phone call.
There are…one you can pay for this, there
are services that provide that.
They charge a lot and I think they’re a
bit of a rip off.
I only think that because I do my own forecasts
based on my own market knowledge but if you
don’t have any access to anything else,
you can pay for that and I forget there are
some big companies that actually do that.
They provide forecasts and they do comp [comparable
sales] reports.
You know they are fancy and they give you
the whole thing and you can take those to
investors and say I’ve got this whole report
done from this company who specializes in
this and they’re credible.
There are sales agents.
So there is a difference between a sales agent
and a distributor, I mean that line is sort
of crossing over a little bit more.
An agent will say this is…what they can
tell you what to expect and they are easier
to get to than distributors.
A distributor generally wants to look at the
movie when it’s finished and that’s why
they’re harder to get to.
They don’t really want to look at the script
or the idea or be pitched on it.
They would be able to tell you and if you
can get to them (and we can talk a minute
about how to get to them) then you can say
I want to make an $800,000 horror film and
it’s going to have this many number of special
effects and no talent and they’ll say expect
to expect to get $800,000 or a million…they
could say that off the cuff over coffee.
They don’t need to go and do analysis or
anything like that.
These people know this and this is what they
do.
So how do you find a distributor?
How do you get an honest answer?
It’s getting tougher and tougher to find
a reputable distributor.
First of all that business is getting tougher.
The world is changing, people’s viewing
habits are changing to consumption of movies
is changing.
I mean a lot of it now is through the streamers,
through the subscription video-on-demand services,
the Netflixs, the Hulus, the Disney Pluses.
It’s easy for consumers.
You’re spending $5.00 to $10.00 a month
and getting an incredible array of fantastic
product.
It’s made movie making such a pleasure (and
television) and look at the quality of product
they’re getting on some of these, I mean
it’s incredible I mean the amount these
streamers spend on product because it’s
a volume game, they can afford it so that’s
making distribution more difficult.
So distributors are falling by the wayside
also so they are getting far and fewer between
and they generally want to deal with bigger
budget product.
They’re not crazy about dealing with lower
budget project for the same reasons a real
estate agent is not as crazy about doing a
$100,000 sale than a $5,000,0000 sale, same
amount of work, much less commission.
So they want to deal with bigger stuff because
they will make more money off of it.
But to find a reputable distributor, I mean
you start…there are different ways you can
go about it depending on who you are and what
your resources are.
I mean you can go to a market like the American
Film Market [AFM] or something like that.
You can register for it, it’s not cheap.
But that will give you access to all of the
distributors who are registered there plus
access to their guide Who Is Registered In
The American Film Marketing Association.
You can do the same with Reed MIDEM who runs
MIPCOM [International Market of Communications
Programmes] or that type of thing.
Like when you register as a buyer or seller
or whatever as an attendee for a major market
like that, half the value is going to the
market and you know hobnobbing and seeing
what goes on and the other half is having
access to the database so now you have say
with the case of MIPTV there are two to three
thousand distributors in that book and in
their database so now you have to contact
them.
You have to reach out and it’s like any
type of networking, you try to be brief, you
explain that you’re a filmmaker making this
kind of movie, here is what it’s going to
be, dress it up a little bit, you’ve got
to sell yourself a little bit and say you
just want to, you’re interested in taking
it to them after the movie is finished but
you want to get an indication of sort of what
budget range you should be working in to make
sure that you’re not going to, that you
have a chance of actually recouping and some
of them will be cooperative.
Like anything else in the world half of them
will be rude and the other ones you know.
And then you just hopefully get lucky and
you get somebody on the phone who is nice
and will give you…or not even on the phone
through an email or whatever the case may
be and if you can’t do it that way you are
going to have to pay to get a report.
Film Courage: And with this report some of
the comps again special effects, no name talent,
what about locations?
How many locations you plan to shoot?
Things like that, does that factor in?
Jeff: Everything factors in depending on who
you get because it’s also subjective but
it doesn’t really totally factor in.
I mean the main component is talent.
If you have a certain level of talent then
it elevates it into a different category see
there are ranges.
It’s not like a total linear thing.
I personally think and again this is just
my opinion right?
But from my experience if you’re dealing
in low-budget indie films stay below about
1.5 maximum.
I used to say two million but 1.5 maximum
because the market is getting tougher and
tougher and tougher to monetize that.
Between 1.5, if once you start getting into
that if you don’t have major talent like
at least somebody who is recognizable then
you’re better off jumping into 5 million.
Like between 1.5 and 5 is almost no man’s
land unless you can figure out how to get
talent in there.
You have a better chance of getting your money
back if you do say a 5 million dollar movie
that has name talent then you do doing a 3
million dollar deal that’s really, really
well done but it doesn’t have name talent
because talent sells.
Most distributors the first question they
ask is who is in it?
And the reason they ask that is because most
consumers ask that because they say “Hey
I heard this movie, who is in it?”
That’s is 90% of what people ask is who
is in it.
And when they recognize somebody they might
take a chance with it.
Film Courage: So if you do got to AFM or MIPCOM
or something like that then you would look
at the distributors and make sure you’re
reaching out to the ones that are going to
be in your genre?
Like don’t…if you have a romcom, don’t
go to an only horror [distributor]?
Jeff: Yes and if you have a narrative don’t
go to a documentary distributor.
Some people only specialize in factual, some
in non-scripted, yes there are special…those
are all listed also, they are all categorized
people when they list…when the distributors
list in the databases they fill out a form
and say this is who were, this is what we
sell, this is what we specialize in, so try
to hone in on the distributor who would be
most suitable to what you’re making.
Film Courage: And keep the email brief?
Jeff: It’s funny, I am talking so much right
now but generally I write super brief emails
and I keep my correspondence super brief and
that is because we live in a world of super
short attention spans.
People don’t like to read a lot.
Everything is sounds bites, everything is
super quick, everything is Twitter feeds and
Instagram posts and stuff like that.
It’s all super, super short and with younger
executives who are now used to all this technology
they just don’t want to read long emails
and don’t want to hear long pitches and
all this kind of stuff, get to the point quickly.
Question for the viewers: Have you ever consulted
with a distributor before making a movie?
Anything you can share about that process?